1080 c'est le nombre de minutes dans une
semaine c'est le temps que passe elliott
seul entre deux séances de thérapie
entre deux séances de thérapie elliott
pour faire face à sa maladie a plusieurs
solutions devant lui la plupart du temps
pour comprendre ce qui lui arrive il y
délivre
mais si statique un livre et sa demande
de la concentration ce qui lui ôte n'a
pas forcément à l'heure actuelle avec sa
maladie elliott a la chance d'avoir une
famille et des amis
alors quand cela ne va pas il va leur
demander de l'aide mais pour sa famille
et ses amis qui le soutiennent depuis
des mois il ya un sentiment d'épuisement
ils se sentent démunis face à cette
maladie et pour elliott demander de
l'aide
c'est reconnaître que cela ne va pas son
estime de soi en prend un coup
et puis il a l'impression que les autres
vont beaucoup mieux que lui qui ne
l'aide pas énormément
elliott comme une grande majorité de la
population française a accès à internet
lors il va sur les forums d'un trade
entre patients avec eux ils échangent ce
qu'il peut vivre dans son quotidien mais
tout comme avec sa famille avec ses amis
ne peut pas tout dire sinon il passera
son temps à dire combien il va mal alors
il se retire un peu qui est finalement
assez frustrant de temps en temps quand
il va vraiment mal
elliott se souvient des exercices
thérapeutiques qui l'a vu avec sa psy en
séance des questionnements pour leur
accorder à ses valeurs profondes mais la
plupart du temps c'est vrai soit il
oublie comment il faut les faire soyez
l'oubli tout simplement de les faire et
puis dans ces moments il oublie ce qui
fait sens pour lui on pourrait dire mais
elliott
si ça va si mal comme ça pourquoi tu ne
rapproche pas des séances de thérapie
le problème c'est que elliott il ne peut
pas faire ça il n'a tout simplement pas
l'argent c'est
situation c'est une situation réelle qui
moi m'a beaucoup touché qui concerne
dans nos de nombreux patients quel que
soit leur pathologie que ce soit une
forme de schizophrénie une forme
d'autisme un trouble de la personnalité
une phobie une anxiété généralisée
envahissante une dépression une
dépression du post partum un trouble
usage de l'alcool ou d'autres substances
un jour ou l'autre ces patients tout
comme vous moi en plus d'attendre entre
leurs séances feront face à des
difficultés avec leurs émotions leurs
humeurs et parfois et même souvent les
deux c'est vrai que si depuis le 19e
siècle
on a beaucoup de formes de thérapie le
principe même de la thérapie lui n'a pas
changé on n'a toujours pas pas freud qui
nous reçoit une fois par semaine sur son
divan jus et le reste du temps on a tout
ce temps tout ce temps qui aurait pu
être employés être plus heureux être
plus fort à faire face à sa maladie
directement depuis son quotidien en fait
qu'il faudrait à ses passions c'est un
outil qui fasse le lien entre les
séances qui les aident à transférer ce
qu'ils ont appris en thérapie
directement chez eux qui les soutiennent
qu'ils les aident à se prendre en main
mais en fait cet outil voilà déjà hélas
tous les jours on utilise notre
téléphone portable pour passer nos
appels
pour répondre à des textos pour aller
sur les réseaux sociaux sauf qu'on sait
que pour un patient avec un troubles
psys aller sur les réseaux sociaux c'est
à double tranchant parce qu'il va se
comparer avec les autres et son humeur
peut vraiment prendre un coup alors
puisque le téléphone portable est partie
de nos vies et si souvent utilisés
pourquoi ne pas faire de cet outil un
outil positif de transformation du
quotidien de ces patients la bonne
nouvelle c'est que ça aujourd'hui on
peut le faire avec
les démocratisation en matière de
nouvelles technologies avec les
innovations en matière d'intelligence
artificielle on peut créer des agents de
conversation c'est ce qu'on appelle des
chat beauté du verbe to chat converser
et boat robot qui permettent de
converser avec les gens directement
depuis messenger c'est ce que j'ai
décidé de faire vous allez me dire un
robot assistant psy attentats temps
n'ont vraiment pas comment ça peut
marcher ton idée là et vous avez raison
sur ce point ce que si on dit
globalement mieux avec les nouvelles
technologies
l'intelligence artificielle telle
qu'elle est à l'heure actuelle manque
d'une chose est une chose qui fait
l'essence même de ce qu'est l'être
humain c'est l'empathie
comment créer un robot empathique qui
parle c'est le cas de le dire aux gens
eh bien on le concret avec et pour et
c'est ce que je suis allé faire je suis
allé sur les forums de soutien entre
passion je leur ai dit voilà je créé un
outil qui vous soutiennent entre vos
séances de thérapie de quoi avez vous
besoin
ensemble on a dégagé trois axes le
premier c'est un soutien disponible 24
heures sur 24 ça un robot il peut le
faire parce qu'il ne se fatigue pas et
comme c'est un robot il est non jugeant
la deuxième chose c'est des exercices
les principes actifs de la thérapie ce
peut être des exercices sur les pensées
quand elle tourne en boucle comme ça
des exercices de relaxation de
méditation de respiration de gestion de
situations de résolution de problèmes
des exercices aussi pour se raccorder à
ses valeurs profondes et la troisième
chose probablement l'une des plus
importante de toutes
c'est l'information parce que pour un
patient savoir ce qu'il a déjà ça
rassure dans quelque sorte l'information
c'est comme l'éducation le savoir
c'est une forme de pouvoir aujourd'hui
ce chat botté c'est un outil gratuit
disponible 24 heures sur 24 utilisé par
des centaines et des centaines de
patients à travers le monde qui va
trouver les patients là où ils se
trouvent déjà là où se trouvent des
millions et des millions de
personnes à travers le monde sur
messenger c'est un chat botté qui a
montré son utilité au sein d'une étude
clinique
la première en france sur un dispositif
qui n'existait même pas il est encore
moins d'un an qui prolonge et augmente
les possibilités de la thérapie parce
qu'il se situe exactement sur le même
principe le dialogue
mais avant toute chose pour moi et pour
les patients avec lesquels j'ai créé ce
chat dont certains sont parmi vous c'est
une façon de démocratiser l'information
à la santé mentale de pouvoir prendre
soin de sa santé psy de façon ludique
sympa décomplexés et de redonner le
pouvoir du changement à la personne qui
se connaît le mieux
et cette personne c'est le patient moi
j'avais simplement à coeur de
transmettre de l'empathie une boîte à
outils à utiliser directement depuis son
quotidien des patients et les nouvelles
technologies m'ont permis de donner plus
d'ampleur plus d'impact à cette volonté
profonde que j'avais de passer d'une
dizaine de patients soutenu comme on
pourrait le faire en cabinet en thérapie
en hospitalier à des centaines de
patients à travers le monde
si moi j'ai pu faire ça sans
connaissance tech sans argent vous aussi
vous pouvez le faire vous pouvez
répondre à des situations qui vous vous
touche personnellement
en partageant vos connaissances avec des
nouvelles technologies mais surtout avec
une chose qui fait ce que vous êtes vous
là unique c'est vos valeurs et votre
sensibilité
merci
[Applaudissements]